when certain family members avoid the
responsibilities for setting and keeping
the house of rules you are asking for
trouble good feeding time is just
bizarre yes I refused to even feed them
yeah that's why we put Greg Murray in
charge so he can kind of handle them
the robbers family dog George I tell you
Prince is breaking another of my primary
rules showing dominance and overly
excited behavior at mealtime out of
frustration Greg and Cathy place all the
responsibility for Prince on their
teenage son Gregory
yawns Gregory's dog where he'll even
actually nip it Gregory bid him a couple
times you say several times so he's very
keen live somewhere else mm-hmm what I
mean your dog is the whole family to go
cuz no one else really like he drives us
except the dog Oh God huh when somebody
says this is her dog or his dog
automatically I have to say is everybody
else's dog cuz that's how the dog sees
each other you know we all family now
this is boundaries okay we're gonna
create boundaries I wanted to teach
every member of the family how to get
Prince into a calm state before they
start the feeding ritual all right so
just the fact that you created an
invisible bubble for him to be away from
food it calms him down see what I'm
doing is I'm claiming he just heard the
bolt there we go perfect give up give up
yeah because the energy that was on the
ball was not nervous fearful hesitant
unsure
it was just claiming the ball I think
this is gonna bring us all together
because we do have to act as a team
instead of individuals in my family we
have new dogs staying with us all the
time what we do is we hold family
meetings and divide up the
responsibility for the dogs exercise
discipline and affection
as evenly as possible that way every dog
learned to respect every member of the
family not just the dog whisperer
but my wife and sons do